everybody it's gary vaynerchuck and this
is a one of my favorite formats of the
content I do this is pod sessions
episode number 10 this one's fun on a
dinner that was done in was at DC in DC
in August two of the three wonderful
individuals were here we were kind of
shooting the [ __ ] I was getting to know
one a little bit better one completely
was a format of a conference series I
was doing around the country where I was
speaking and then there was a dinner
series at night and they were there
jamming and just kind of like popped in
my head and we were talking about our
third individual I said you know what
why don't we just all get together and
do a pod sessions because I because I
felt I remember thinking wow a lot of
this conversation a lot of what I
thought the third individual could bring
to the conversation would make
tremendous content for the things that I
care about whether it's marketing or
actually building an actual business or
practicality or siphoning from a career
to an entrepreneur just a lot of themes
so I'm super excited about this I've got
a good sense of where I want to take it
I'm like you know this one's a little
more under the radar pod pod sessions
meaning you know we've been bringing
people with huge audience and things
that nature just a little bit more of
you know individuals that I admire
pieces of and I thought if we put it all
together we could really make a nice
meal so I'm excited why don't we go
around and introduce ourselves and why
don't we start to the left and go into a
kind of circle man tell Abreu tell the
vaynernation who you are so my name is
Dylan leisure
I'm from Hagerstown Maryland small town
in Maryland most of you probably never
heard of it before just recently moved
in New York and part of that yeah and
working for one of your good friends
eight on Sugarman mhm
managing socials for the huntin fish
Club and for southern hospitality and
that's because your background is also
in a little bit of that world right yeah
so for like the past two years and so up
until I moved to New York I was
rebranding and renovating my father's
restaurant bar like back home in
Maryland and ended up at that dinner
with you and then things transpired and
just kind of took the leap of faith and
was like moved in New York and take this
step so I love it
let's keep going everybody Revere Sutton
uh what else my say
and I forgot that fast I'm originally
from DC moved to Northern Virginia when
I was 10 and owned a business called
forward think selling technology
services and products to the government
primarily how long you been doing that
I've had my own company for eight years
but I've been in the field for over 20
yep yep how are you I'm great I love you
here sir
Steve sheets from Altoona Pennsylvania
chairman now the sheets family council
I've been like bottled boy and
dishwasher and helped build this
business from one store to 586 doors
through the years and for the people
that live in different parts of the
world what are the stores good question
yes
like you you've probably never seen long
so you haven't so it's it's it's a
convenience store we start out as a
dairy store and then as times changed
and people's demands for food changed
and then we had to add gasoline in the
in the 70s when the blue laws went away
we love the blue laws sheets because
everybody was closed Sundays except us
so everybody came the sheet so it was a
it was a dairy store with a big deli and
then now we've really and why were you
able to the blue laws because I know
because of the liquor industry why why
did uh why was sheets able to be open
because of the gasoline well because we
had less than 15 employees at the time
at per store in other words it was that
was that the essence of the blue laws oh
yes the blue laws were different in
different states yeah that's what I
think in Pennsylvania was you had to
have like less than 10 or 15 employees
so there were no supermarkets no
Walmart's it was all us so a Sunday was
like five ten times normal day because
we the other thing open we love that and
then liquor license - we don't that's
where you stay control the pole right
now we just hit a hundred stores with
beer we've been fighting it since I came
out of college 1969 we had three stores
and we pushed for beer yeah and we push
for self-serve gas we got self-service
it's a very important part of this story
you graduated college you said Oregon
State
1969 right and that you know so you
graduated college the year the New York
Jets won the super there you go anyway
12th that year the New York Jets changed
the football landscape forever
I love that so Namath yeah Joe Namath so
some of my favorite Jets of all time for
Penn State alums Lance Mel one of my
favorite favorites anyway nonetheless so
got it and so you that your parents
started no my well yeah it's a long
story but we came out of the dairy
business
my grandfather back you know my father
then sought the whole business changing
he opened one store and then five stores
during World War two then my brother
came along took over one so 1960 I went
to work with him with with your brother
yeah yeah and then he said I went to
school actually be a math teacher you
did
he said come with me we're gonna open
ten stores and so I went with him
well Tintin and he said let's open a
hundred and we opened a hundred and he
said I'm going to Florida and he left is
that what happened back in 1983 and it's
still there we still just send him the
check down there yes right so you jumped
in in 83 to kind of yeah well I yeah you
know I was I was really managing all but
I learned that year the difference the
next five years between a manager a
leader which I really didn't know but it
was gonna hit me hard
that was a super interesting segue right
so yeah you're in this but this is
something that I talk to a lot of kids
about transitioning from a doer to a
manager and then from a manager to being
the last line of defense the leader you
know hear a bunch of kids are listening
a bunch of people are listening but have
so many young listeners as well I'm
listening and I'm saying you were in the
business every day for 14 years
presumably as minimally the number two
probably closer to the 1b and that even
though at that age on that transition
going from either two or one bead to one
a there was a five year learning curve
in the way that you put it on making
that transition from just that small of
a jump perceived but I know and you know
is actually the biggest jump of them all
that's correct what was the biggest
shocking thing from being how would you
could consider yourself would you
consider you were 1b or do you consider
you were the two just something out of
curiosity I'm sure it's just some folks
yeah I would say one because I ran all
of operation I would say so too so so
what was the biggest shock in that
transition well the biggest shock was
that I I thought I was a good manager
yeah actually a great manager which
meant that I I took this cookie cutter
that we had developed and open the store
it was I knew how to hire people I knew
how to to do the architecture you and I
need I mean you every day that's right
did create that kind of factory to open
those kind of stores people locations
that's a system but but the world around
me was changing but as a manager I just
kept putting this kind of cookie cutter
out every day but the world was changing
and I wasn't changing with it you know I
was managing today's business but wasn't
thinking about where we were headed
that's right tomorrow and we were in
that we had to find a way to make that
transition and by the end of that five
years I finally knew where the hell we
were going and where was that we had the
treasure ever yeah we had to go from a
take home store where people were making
sandwiches eating at home to a store
where people were eating on the run it
was a grab-and-go but now we had 158
stores that we had to make a transition
we had wouldn't you go fit the new model
you were kids at home you to go from
being more like a deli metal rarity to a
7-eleven of today mentality yeah and
with better food hopefully yes of course
absolutely so that's exactly right
because you had the advantage of coming
from a better food place but we had to
talk with customers to find out where we
were supposed to go and employees and
then he told us so now we developed this
whole new model 1988 now we had one
store that fit the vision of where we're
headed which store was that that was do
you remember well what's in store 158 no
I see what you did indeed you made the
next one and next
we had every customers told us they
wanted and how did it do it did great
but now a hundred fifty-seven they had
to figure out what they do with those
it's hard and so we really slow down and
slow down expansion so I'm now it made
we have been we had to go back and
reassess every store could they fit that
do you sell off any stores because they
we do yeah very good question
listen I'm an operator we had 15 in
Pittsburgh that did not fit where we're
headed very difficult advantage we had
11 restaurants that we had broke it off
into we sold those if we concentrate
here is the vision and I said this is
where we're headed now we've got to
determine which stores we can rebuild
remodel relocate and that was where we
were headed for you and so let's let's
piggyback off this theme that we're
building on you made the transition from
doing what you do well and you
understood four companies yeah
to then doing so many people this in
rate our in they like to say they're
intrapreneurs and they say that to me
because they're trying to act cool
because they think entrepreneurship is
cool and I'm always like don't worry
being a great employees and remarkable
like it's really funny I'm far more
associated myself with being self-aware
than I do being an entrepreneur like I
would have been pumped to be the number
three or number 17 or to make 47
thousand a year and work 41 hours a week
and have fun doing all the other things
I just want to be happy right what I
ended up being was an entrepreneur so
I'm fascinated by a lot of people who
say they're entrepreneurs and they
intrapreneur talk falls into two things
people who are scared to make the leap
into entrepreneurship for a million
different reasons judgment yeah their
cash they like lit their like their
lifestyle and they don't want to give up
some of the luxuries for a year or two
and then other people who are actually
not anything close to an entrepreneur it
just makes them feel better being an
employee when when did you know they
tell me the trip give me the whole
narrative because I think you represent
something very important to my audience
and the world and so I like you and I've
know you the most out of this table
we've interacted here and there at any
time thank you
what what did you from day one yeah
you know after you were managing a whole
bunch of stuff and you're like [ __ ] I
don't need anybody else
when the when the boss pissed you off
like what was it yeah
so my parents were both business owners
my dad's a veterinarian he had a clinic
my whole life my mom owned a children's
book store like from the end of
elementary school to high school right
so you were and you were in it so I knew
yeah every weekend every every you know
how all summer yeah we muster break or
like to go hang out with our damn friend
no you're coming with us so I feel so I
went the trajectory of I'm gonna go to
school and I was I was a average student
I never really liked school the only
classes I took two or business classes
in high school which I got an A in and
everything else was like now if I get a
see him okay and there wasn't a lot of
structure at home in terms of like
helping with homework and things like
that so we were kind of like be
self-motivated and I was so I always had
a job I was you know babysitting selling
bracelets and stuff at the county fair
and things like that and then I went to
school I always worked so retail you
know temporary work and when I was a
freshman in college I got a job at a
small government contracting firm and
started answering phones part-time and
they liked my work they were wowed that
I managed to like learn the switchboard
in an hour when I was taking you know
you're smart the older women like days
right look I grew up in my dad's liquor
store similar kind of background you
know have this company like to me always
and I'm sure you remember this you know
like there's no high for a manager or an
owner that's greater than seeing
somebody come in at the entry level and
be smart and get it because because you
start dreaming about their potential
right you got you're happy for them
you're like oh yeah I just remember I'm
like Shaniqua
Shaniqua Williams I remember at Wine
Library she was smart as [ __ ] I just
remember like looking at her one day on
the register I'm like she won't be there
long you know and like that's fun so
nonetheless I understand that reaction
from them so by sophomore
I was taking I was working full-time
taking all my classes at night and by 21
I was making like $40,000 without my
degree yet and yeah and the money was
good and and this is not yesterday so 40
young yeah this is honest I'm 41
yes you know 20 years ago 40 is 80 just
to tell you so keep going right um and
so I worked my ass off but most of the
companies I worked for the culture was
not where I needed it to be it didn't
match my potential it didn't match the
things I was looking for and so I never
really lasted anywhere more than three
years and the you know predominant
wisdom still now is like oh no you have
to work somewhere for a year two years
three years five years whatever don't
screw up your resin yes you can't be
resin you know you can't be job hopping
and I'm like no I'm good and then the
other thing is people are scared because
like oh the grass is not gonna be
greener on the other side and it's like
it's more secure you weren't scared
though because you had grown up with it
yes got it and I just have a very like
did you like die to my core question you
think like even at 21 even at 24 when
you're like oh wait a minute this might
be the industry I [ __ ] with like I'm
into it yeah I'm gonna have my own thing
definitely that's well like I needed
some structure that these businesses
were gonna give me and obviously in
hindsight I was like no you should have
started this ten years ago right but it
is what it is it just what it yeah
and it gave me a good Network and so
when did you do it 33 so eight years ago
mm-hmm okay eight year anniversary on
the 10th and so you know what's the
biggest things that you're thinking
about these days like what do you feel
scaling scaling so what's going on um so
when I was so burnt out just emotionally
physically just from when I left in 2010
oh boy so I had gone back to school in
the middle of this and got my MBA and
just was in a in a culture this was a
big company now and I love the people I
supported locally but the people I
reported in to and another state just
[ __ ] and just you know I remember
one day this one of my bosses that I had
like five and a five-year period
me into his office and he starts yelling
at me and I look around I'm like who the
[ __ ] are you talking to like my dad
doesn't talk to me like that my husband
doesn't talk to me like that you're not
gonna talk to me like that I'm gonna be
in my office and when you can be
professional sure come see me and it
just became like this really contentious
thing and I was traveling a lot my kids
were young and it sucked so when I left
I was just like focused on making up my
salary and like spending time with my
kids
right and I feel like a lot of why I've
been packing violence it yeah absolutely
so for the first five years I was really
just like happy to be able to pay my
bills and wasn't really worried yeah
and in the last three now I'm like okay
let's let's go my kids you know my
youngest is 15 Leila and Joey's 16 and
I'm the big boys and girls now yes and
my husband is great and he's a better
parent so I can leave with him I've got
a big family support system so yeah it
works
and now level down I feel like you know
I've been and now I'm ready to do this
and how many employees do you have 15
yeah that's great time to scale yeah I
love it okay let's keep going so back to
transitions which is what we've been
talking about you're in the midst of a
really interesting one you know you I
know you you know what just filling
everybody who's listening you actually
worked right on a project right you were
in school
that's how you were so I was and I was
in Steve's entrepreneurship program yep
um called the sheets Fellows Program
it's like an entrepreneurial Leadership
Program under the second there a
different campus within the Penn State
EKOS room right and State Altoona yeah
yeah and so you worked on it oh so it
was his school got his clothes
yes his program yeah and and so you went
from that you you told me about the
flipping with the apartments and mom and
like the video game stuff I'm just
filling everybody in then you are are
you done with school and you go home to
start rebranding and like kind of
marketing and helping out with your
dad's things so I spent about just like
five or six months and um I worked under
this lady named Colleen divorce right
and she helped with the sheets
rebranding in the early 2000s right yeah
so I went I worked for her for about
five to six months like I said
and I got to a point where you know I
just want to take a next step grow you
know as a person then you want to work
for her from a branding marketing kind
of stage yes so sure it was more
traditional and you were supposed to
bring some of the social digitalize yes
good and then you decide six months and
you're like you know what I'm gonna go
do this and execute against my dad's
mm-hmm rebranding of his this place yes
correct and you do that for two years
yeah and so back to transitions you
school you go and work for somebody then
you transition to do it for your family
business where I assume you had a lot
more autonomy mm-hmm how long have you
been into this hunt and fish project
this would be my third week right so
even in the first 15 17 21 days what's
the biggest transition from doing it in
place where you're like I'll [ __ ] you
dad I'm doing this - oh [ __ ] I've got
somebody who's like is it my dad who I
can just yell at or just take it I'm
like what's the this is almost a reverse
you've you've got you're doing something
super interesting and thoughtful in my
opinion so I'm fascinated by it a lot
everyone's talking about I want to go do
my own thing and not that it was your
own thing but I'm sure you have a hell
of a lot more time I mean you're now
making decision wait a minute I want to
go too and I assume your head maybe
bigger leagues New York City but not
having the time you're going almost
weirdly the reverse what's the first
jump in the pool first three weeks kind
of feeling um tell the truth it's it's a
little bit important it's it's a little
different because I won't let a top are
you and I want to bring value for
everybody's watching alyssum it's
different because you know that it
there's a checks and balances system now
right so you know learning to work right
when you screwed up before you can make
pretend there wasn't a screw-up right
and just get away with it a family
business yeah but with this you can't do
that can't yeah not at all no but I'm
sure right yeah it is true you know you
can kind of hide behind the curtain when
you're coming and I'll tell it as a kid
who was in a family business that had
carp launch
I would always yell at my dad back not
about the micro loss which I had plenty
of it was the macro win any time he'd be
like that I didn't why did we spend
$4,000 on those coupons we didn't get
anything like dad
at the end of the year you are more than
welcome to kick me out of this place but
let's look at it as a whole not this
week in May
and the truth is I want to give him a
lot of credit he didn't have a whole lot
of that energy was more of just a look
of like you know like okay why do we
waste money you know you would have that
in a family business here you've got a
new boss you've got a like prove
yourself right 100% and what are you
most excited about in the first three
weeks I think just being immersed in a
totally different type of culture New
York City you know speed speed
being around people who have you know
like a lifestyle is kind of like more
than where I'm from yes you say you mean
the fellow employees and yes being
connected with vending money I'm dumb
[ __ ] after the what is the calibration
of the New York speed so far has it been
super fast or you dicted to it there's a
lowly shell of it I was always like want
to go back home right and now it's just
like I'm wanting to go but I'm just like
I'm in the city right it's not just like
you're running is the same speed let's
go back around this would be a lot of
fun I'm gonna take it into a different
place real quick and I will keep going I
want to know what you're obsessed with
right now and I don't mean in the
context of everything we just talked
about like you're pumped about some new
excel formula that's helping I'm scared
I'm sure what are you just excited about
that's happening in culture whether it's
a TV show whether it's a new product
that you use in the bathroom whether
it's you know some you know an
experience you had what's what I love is
the zeitgeist you know what I loved sir
listening to you talk I'm like oh I know
why he was successful if you actually
are consumer centric you will always win
the only reason I get to sit here and
people think I've got one pitch I always
say I'm Mariano Rivera I got one pitch I
don't care about my feelings I'm pure
humility to the end consumer I grew up
with lemonade stands baseball card shows
and a liquor store I've been retail for
my whole life all I know is watching the
eyes watching the reactions using my
intuition to what felt good to the other
person the market is my king Lord
religion nothing else so I always love
this question because I think you know
I always think that's what I'm trying to
pay attention to why are people wearing
rips and their jeans again like they
won't in the eighties wired why are long
hair back why the haircuts styles foods
like systems all that stuff I love all
that stuff so that's what I love and
that's what I caught when you said I had
to listen to the customers and my
employees you're absolutely right that's
where all the answers are they're not in
vain and McKinsey's fancy decks from
Harvard they're in the trenches they
always will be but on that same kick
what I the reason I made that statement
was one I want to pay you a compliment
cuz I would really loved you saying that
- it's about listening so what are you
listening to now or what are you seeing
what are you obsessed by let's let's
start with you what's the most
interesting thing going on that's tough
I think for me it's just like nine to be
selfish but just like my life right now
because everything in my life has
changed drastically in the past two
months yeah so just trying to like get
acclimated to like where I used to be in
like where I'm at now and just like
being there just enjoying it yeah just
yeah it's like I'm just I wake up every
day I'm happy like I'm passionate like
the action yes 100% I love it I am
obsessed with besides your content is a
form of interment fasting called 4:3
where you eat four days a week and fast
three days a week for 36 hours okay so
this is super interesting because I
don't know what this is but I'm gonna
keep asking you the reason I apologize
for jumping in is I'm actively fasting
today for this is the third week in a
row
I used to fast a lot one day a week
mm-hmm a couple years ago when I really
lost my weight it really worked the last
couple years the last 18 months I've
been far more focused on flexibility
soft tissue work a little muscle gain
which has been amazing yeah but I gained
enough weight we're like just you know
when you weight yeah I just don't want
to feel nice in my clothes you just want
to feel great that's was like okay if I
can just get seven to eleven off real
that you know and the thing that works
for me is fasting but for me I would
fast for a full day which usually meant
I wouldn't eat for about 36 yeah powers
it's like for three days a week
Stefanie ruthless so I do Sundays
Tuesdays Thursdays so something you
don't need so Saturday not easy I
thought yeah 10:10 p.m. on Saturday for
real so Saturday I would eat for real I
would stop eating at Batman okay then
Monday so today so I thought yesterday
today I would break my fast at 10 a.m.
okay so you have to sleep on both nights
part of yeah and the reason why did I
was doing the intermittent fasting like
that everyone else is doing for a while
which is like the sixteen eight where
you eat like during an eight hour window
so like 11 - whatever but I was that's
like a fake fast and I feel like you
have to go past 20 like you have to go a
full 24 hours for it to really matter my
opinion I agree and it's just like
normal life did you when you were in
your career where you eat or during the
day or now during the day yeah yeah but
I could run it off I know and you also
have food all around you it's really
funny like you forget it so hard I never
I've never I have net into lysed
actually what's really ironic four years
ago when I started trying to lose weight
was the first time in my life that I
ever ate lunch that's my big thing where
I was getting caught was no breakfast no
lunch but I would eat like a machine at
dinner and that would always be like 9
p.m. and I would eat like 4,000 calories
you know like no but I'm my body is so
it's so easy for me to fast if I can get
over the dinner hump because having
breakfast and lunch is not natural to me
writers of retail yeah I saw I think
it's the same thing I mean how long you
been doing it this is like my third or
fourth week maybe wait I feel great and
I don't mind the fasting the other thing
is with traveling like it's it's hard
you're can't you can't prep but bus so
I'm just like no this is so much easier
to implement it for me because I don't
want to be counting my calories and I'm
still trying to eat well on a piece of
yeah piece of content um I don't know
what just watching but there's a lady
named soo Miah Kazi who was on The Today
Show or something and they entered
her about this and she had like $100
little plan and I downloaded it just
have something I love it to be
accountable sir
yes what are you obsessed with right now
well I'm says I'm obsessed with watching
the next generations and of our business
so when when I started we had eight
employees five of us were family members
and we had this business today we have
19,000 employees but the thousand family
members and there's there's a hundred
and one descendants of our parents and
there's 15 working so now I'm kind of
the last of the first generation our
second and third and I'm watching this
electric car coming and I'm watching our
gas business you know I'm looking at the
futures and this gasp is just slowly
going away and what are these next
generations gonna do here because
they're dealing with it right now in
terms of do you think they have the DNA
that your dad and you you and your
brother had where you were willing to
put yourself out of business in the
short term I think we do you know that's
our vision to put sheets as we know it
today out of business that's our vision
but I'm watching the next generations
and and I'm still there so I can I can
feel it with them and I notice them a
little bit you know and how did they
take the nudge didn't take it as Yoda as
like wise or do they take it as like the
[ __ ] I think they take it I think
they tell me one thing
no dad they're really thinking get the
[ __ ] out of here right yeah I think
that's what they're thinking you don't
think you have the most leverage with of
the of the family members internally and
what's her his position well I don't
know Larry's with but leverage I mean
there is that wisdom respect and well
you can see she like but I'm starting
you know I'm starting to feel it was the
second and third generation and there
are some that are so damn sharp it's
unbelievable I knew they were sharp but
do they have that feeling that says you
know that competitive spirit this is we
got to make it and entitlement that you
and I didn't grow up so another fault
there's some reality some of its timing
too some of them think they want to run
away from this gas business you know and
I'm like you can't run away from it when
we sign this leased for 25 years or
whatever it is you know we're signing it
based on this gas volume and profits
it's not going away tomorrow and then
they say to me while I'm said to me you
know you
got your head in the sand I said no I
don't have my head in the sand I'm just
trying to make sure we get the timing
right here you know of transitioning
without gas it's like you just said
something really really important that
I'm gonna harp on for everybody
listening who a lot of you're trying to
figure me out and I keep saying watch
what I do not what I say and more
importantly I do break this down but for
some reason people don't hear it I
always talk about I don't a lot of
people want to give me credit for
predicting the future and I'm always
like I'm not Nostradamus I don't predict
I'm just good at what's already happened
you're talking about a very important
thing that you and I clearly share know
it I had a funny feeling just on the
narrative that we would have some
similarities but as I'm listening it's
even maybe even further than I thought
I'm a humongous believer in not overly
respecting the past but not being too
ideological about the future and I
almost see everybody caught in one of
the two and I'm listening to you and I'm
like oh [ __ ] he's not he's more like me
which is he's not head-in-the-sand loved
what got him here I've just been
listening to your words but in my
business everyone's like Gary Vee are a
are even voice that I'm very passionate
about with Alexa if you noticed watch
what I do not what I say I established
it's coming but I've been unbelievably
quiet for the last six months mainly
because the progress is slow and I'm not
excited about it I couldn't agree more
you have people come in they want to
make them not this is not what you're
saying but for everybody listening I'm
watching a lot of people come into
businesses whether kids or whether
executives and they want to make their
mark and the way they think they can
make their mark is by betting on the
future and then looking right the
problem is sometimes it takes longer
than you think the problem is sometimes
you give up something that's valuable
yes do I think Electronic Arts sure I
also think self-driving cars are going
to be a very important variable because
then you can make b2b deals not with
individuals if there's only four
companies that control all the cars one
the they don't need the middleman of the
gas station it could be macro deals with
Exxon or you know or Shell or whoever
nonetheless we all know those things are
coming but I think what your experience
in my experience look in 1998 in 1998
when I took over operations for my dad's
business
two years after I launched
winelibrary.com ecommerce I thought by
the year 2000
everybody's gonna be buying wine for me
on the internet and I've got to go crazy
now it worked out for me because I was
right about the macro so betting the
farm with frantic pace on the Internet
was good but if I was a VC or had a big
company not a small company that didn't
have money I would have definitely over
invested we just didn't have any money
so I just invested but you know we
didn't have a credit line we weren't
funded we weren't a big company so if I
was running vaynermedia as a 22 year old
I would have wasted a lot of money I
just didn't have the luxury of not
having is very powerful I think you're
absolutely right like plenty of cars are
gonna go into gas stations in four years
lots of them
absolutely it's just there's nothing
that's happened yet that would make me
think that's not the case no I mean if I
did I wouldn't be signing 20 25 year
leases because look it's 20 25 years
like who knows right like that's that's
a ways but to your point I start ripping
out gas stations yes would be insanity
it might be a you I might with you if we
were like two people I'd be like hey do
we want to completely build a model 25
years from today on gas stations that's
an interesting debate correct ripping
out gas stations would be insanity and I
think let's look back at history as well
the first 20 years we spent without
gasoline we didn't have gasoline then
all of a sudden you'd be able to
pendency on gas way but you know going
forward you know we don't have to be a
station we have to look at our core
competencies yeah we can operate in six
states we know how obvious ly to to
create a culture in an atmosphere where
people want to thrive and you have to
look at the core competencies and say
what else can we do you know we can run
restaurants we can run car we can run
you know one of the core cops think
outside of the convenience store
business what else can we run or in the
same way that the biggest transition the
company ever really made was you know
you didn't go into full detail but there
was a transition at some point of
supplying dairy in one form and then
deciding to be the retailer of it right
exactly
look I mean I think you know I would
argue that your company has permission
to be
the transportation infrastructure in
some shape or form your company
absolutely could have been the people
that invented the electronic scooters
that we see in develop you could I could
I mean I you you absolutely could and I
think Nintendo started as a playing card
company the biggest movies in Hollywood
are made from something that started off
as a comic book company superhero movies
right so I do think when you take to
your point the energy it's about finding
new containers and merchandising them
right and you know we go outside like we
spent three days in Seattle washcloths
we got to visit Amazon to get the visit
you know don't have any cash yeah we
went into the store up there could open
3,000 of them in the next three years
you know who wants to go into a store
where you have to waste four minutes for
a cashier when you can just grab and go
exactly then we get to meet with the
innovation officer at Starbucks with 60
people working with her and so we're out
there just kind of looking at
carnegie-mellon we spent you know three
days with last month which is constantly
out there looking but I see that in the
next generation of th I'm happy with you
know and so where are you spending your
physical time are you still well I've
got the sheets fellows so I teach twelve
times a semester I mentor some of the
students I got the Family Council we
just met the other day you know we study
businesses that failed as well as those
family businesses that survived and one
of the biggest reasons they fail is that
the family ceases to get along so we've
got 101 family members 15 work as you go
in time the bigger percentage doesn't
work but own stock and they want to sell
out I want cash and then you got this
inner group saying that works there I
want to hold on and that's the constant
the battle so as the sheets family
council and the head of it I'm trying to
keep the family together so we do a
retreat we we get together Thanksgiving
together Christmas and we're together
all the time and we're trying to hold us
together because for that family we want
to be a privately
family business that's a question yep
you went through this important
transition of five years right from
going from an operator to a leader
that's correct
I have to assume like it's very I don't
know anything and I already know that
you're a disproportionate glue to this
ambition I assume you at this point are
giving a lot of thought to who becomes
the glue when you decide not to be the
glue is that where you're spending a lot
of time thinking - well some of it I
mean when multiple people be the glue
because I've been thinking a lot about
that - well you know when when my
brother was CEO we had a rule we
actually established that one person one
family would be the last one to say yes
one decision-maker no he chastised to me
then he passed it to iPad leaving it to
my nephew but the next one came along
and said unless you're I'm comfortable
with that so now we have three it's me
it's it's my two nephews there's three
of us so when I phase out I face out you
know in two years off of kind of the
Family Council the other two have to
agree we have to agree on who this third
third interesting yeah so it was one one
one and then the next one said I'm not
comfortable with one making all this
decision for this three so now we'll
decide which one's the next what else is
going on your world what at what else do
you want entrepreneurs executives other
people to know think or what questions
you ever um
so I'm focused the the scaling part on
really
we have been pivoting from like a pure
consulting company to where we supported
a bunch of technology companies
privately we're trying to get into the
government business as well as the
federal government you know providing IT
services and so now we're building out
this IT plus model which I haven't fine
we haven't finalized yet but basically
you know building on what you guys were
just talking about this whole digital
transformation that every company has to
be really
thinking about how do you do business
and how are you using technology to get
that business done oh my god and I
always tell people it's like electricity
and they're failing when electricity
first came around there was businesses
yeah like and if you were not a business
that's decided electricity was a good
idea you probably lost over time yeah
that was obvious because it was as
Extreme as like dark and the Sun went
down in your business out of clothes to
have it right but I don't think people
understand how being fully digital right
like in your core is a requirement and
an enabler of growth right they're still
looking at it like IT is the cost center
that's the support mechanism versus all
freights yeah absolutely so we're you
know we've built a small development
factory where people can outsource their
development needs so if they have you
know constraints on the IT folks
in-house and I shoot left field question
yes it's never you know we've talked
about this privately and I think you
haven't evaluated people how much are
you thinking about like being a
successful entrepreneur is an incredible
accomplishment I you know I think I
think people just think that you slap it
on your body you know you guys know have
my spiel I'm very worried that people
think it's easy now and the Internet has
made it easier no question the cogs are
so different cost of goods yeah like it
doesn't cost a million bucks to build a
[ __ ] store right like you needed
money for the bricks and the wood and
whatever the first study you know had
you know like it still lead money there
wasn't like I'm gonna be on Instagram
all day from a year and that's gonna
give me leverage and I can actually
inspect print these t-shirts wallet
before I get the I'm gonna say I have
the t-shirts but I don't I'm gonna take
their money then I'm gonna use like you
couldn't do things that I mean I would
have never graduated high school but you
know at the same token that
entrepreneurships on his pedestal what I
am super passionate about is this is
what the Internet has done is we can now
see entrepreneurs in all shapes and
sizes and you know how passionate I am
about that yes you are a successful
female minority entrepreneur you're also
smart so I want to ask you to put this
question selfishly cuz I'm curious
what's going through your mind are you
being affected by knowing
that you sit in a very strong leverage
point now as an individual and and are
you affected by you know minority women
DMing you or emailing you if they can if
they find out about you like how much
are you thinking about like wow this is
an interesting era for what I'm doing
I've a I've gone through the chapter of
now doing it successfully for a long
enough period of time that even the
toughest filters will be like no no you
are one yeah are you thinking about that
and and then do you get into the world
of like wait a minute all these years
were it was potentially potentially
where was a disadvantage
could I be going into an era where it's
an advantage how do I take advantage of
that like how are you thinking about
this moment in time that is clearly must
be interesting to see through you know
I'm seeing it through my eyes which are
different than yours what do you think
about all that
so I def I think throughout my life I've
always been like you I think like all
most entrepreneurs in this kind of
advisory position with my family with my
friends with colleagues and so I've done
a lot of counseling a lot of free [ __ ]
for people for years just because I
could because I feel like if I know
something I'm not going to not tell you
because I'm supposed to charge you for
it I think right now no my head is like
I'm 100% down focused on like building
this company good for you and whatever
comes along the way I'm open to but I'm
not I've never been focused on like what
I look like or who I am I'm just like no
I mean if I can get it done what about
speaking and books and being on CNBC
like those are the things that are gonna
start populating through your mind or
brought to you without bringing it to
you right now yeah I would I would be
open to it
it's not my focus right now but I would
I would totally be you're aware that
that's in the air ish yes cool what do
you what do you think how are you
thinking about this without you know
saying my master plans to work there for
a year and then bounce with Asia getting
mad
don't worry I'll protect him like how
are you thinking about this chapter like
let me go prove it in the big leagues
and then decide what I feel like yeah I
mean that's pretty much my plan you know
I spent you know the past two years
really focused on
proof of concept right can I actually do
something and make it successful not not
that my dad's restaurant wasn't
successful but like you know build it up
because you know we increased sales
about 40 percent in the past two years
he's on track to make a million this
year which he's never he's never hit so
the special number one yeah so you know
that's one of his goals that he's always
wanted to do and to achieve so like so
now you want to see can I do that again
in a different way yeah yeah for
somebody else and then what are you
intuitively like if you had a guess what
then happens do you build an agency
around that skill set or do you actually
build a restaurant hospitality business
with that being your secret sauce yeah
I'm C I'm torn and as you should be I'm
torn because let you smart
I grew up debate I grew up in the
industry I know it you know second
nature to me but oh by the way I'm sure
both of us will say and even though what
you mean you did us from such a young
age such a big advantage that people run
away from like when you know something
that cold yeah it's a competitive
advantage yeah so like but also like I
know things from a branding marketing
perspective that can help right sure
other businesses not just only
restaurants or but I got it so just
trying to figure out where I want to
take it right now I got a group of
creatives so we have this like a little
group and we do like side projects right
now that's right I remember you telling
me over in ER you've got different
creative directors or a copywriter
designer that you've picked up along the
way and you got a little kind of like
freelance crew right yeah so just like
figuring out that and then like kind of
like being the leader of the crew and
holding a job maybe less flexibility do
so just learning on the fly for real but
I think for me right now just solely
focused on you know improve helping aids
on improve everything he has one one
what uh what parting shots or questions
do we have as we wrap up here sir
I don't know about say hit me though
that was 1969 when I come out of college
the first year we did a million and then
1999 we did a billion and then this year
we're over seven billion
you know you wait a minute oh by the way
just for anybody else a million in 1969
was like seven billion right no it's
really it's really ruined privately-held
I mean not you guys we've laid it out to
be a privately held family business as
my brothers and I say we we're the last
of the first generation keep the kids at
home we were talking about top-line
revenue numbers right right yes your
table so you know for example
vaynermedia this year and the Vayner X
family because I own some publishing
house I'm super proud that we'll be
close to 200 million yet we made no
money and I'm not and I didn't lose
money I don't have VCS I don't have
credit I'm doing it cuz I'm reinvesting
absolutely talk to everybody at home you
know we heard the 1 million the billion
the 7 billion for for as much as you can
remember and I have a funny feeling
you're gonna remember were you guys the
kind of operators and family that wanted
to always have perhaps like in the
lexicon of like as long as my salaries
paid and we can eat put every dollar
back into business because we can open
another store when did the transition
because there's no way you got to this
if you didn't in the early days invest
everything back yeah see this one I tell
the students I I sat on a bank board and
and on the loan loan committee and we
learned to identify the the people who
who were running a lifestyle business
they ran a lifestyle but they were not
putting it in my brother did not
increase his lifestyle and those early
guys even when we hit that man we were
pushing we were pushing vendors to put
in all the shelving for free to put in
the equipment for free we were pushing
everybody yeah and we were not buying
buildings or random because our core
competency was running these stores not
in real estate did you ever get into
real estate not not in baby in the snail
no compared to the scale that you are no
you guys understood your core competency
yeah we make money because we know the
damn business we don't know what a real
estate mr. I'll tell you I would argue
that not pushing my dad my dad loved the
thought of real estate you know and we
spent way too much money building this
superstore in New Jersey that I
intuitively won but I wasn't strong
enough so I don't want to I don't like I
should
have pushed harder to say dad we're
awesome at running wine and liquor
stores let's forget about the ideology
of owning being your own landlord all
that money that we are about to tie up I
could open up seven goddamn stores and
dominate it exactly that you understood
it yeah that's what we did and the bank
wouldn't give us money you talk about
not making money we didn't he sees like
me running around running dumb checks Oh
money was tough money was so hard we
pushed everybody so back to my question
what are the first 10-15 years
unbelievably dollars back into the
system and was what was there a
transition the board became well more
about maybe taking a little bit more
profit to avoid some of the fruits of
the labor the bank wanted us to one
story year we were hungry we want to
store so in nineteen I'm inai just kept
asking how do I get money in 1972 I
found out the he said pay your supplier
slower you know payment 45 days we did
we went from 7 to 14 stores in one year
we almost didn't make it I mean we were
bending we were on bended knees for the
bank you know and fortunately the banker
gave me money gave us money or we'd have
been in trouble but we went from 7 to 14
really taught us a lesson we almost did
not make it through number 15 but I
always claim I got mine my masters and
my doctorate that year what we learned
and but we didn't have a lot of money I
get it it's later on when we start we
need to start spending something I get
it final thoughts uh thank you for
having me um no this is great appreciate
what I know you consume the content
anything lately that's caught your eye
yeah I was watching I was watching a
bunch of it last night in my room um I
you know I think that something you guys
were talking about here that hit you
yeah it's just like the leadership
aspect
most companies leadership sucks because
they're because they're driven by money
there or or building their fiefdom
yeah hundred percent well there's a
difference between the leadership like
him and I and you have the luxury right
now of being the last line of defense so
there's a difference between leader
ship and leaders me I am so different
than my nine c-suite executives
you couldn't even compare us you know
not half of them but like I watched them
try to build up motes to protect
themselves and I have empathy for that
it gets scary when you're a top five top
10 employee you make a lot of money
right especially if you have me as a
boss and I already have a funny feeling
you if you actually like your CEO and
he's like you're doing well and you like
it
well now you're even double scared to
lose that job because you're like yeah I
could probably make that money somewhere
else but not as happily so I've watched
people around me even be more aggressive
to protect themselves because they're
like oh [ __ ] this is the Golden Goose
this is money and nice like [ __ ] I don't
want to lose this but I have empathy for
that and to your point leadership a lot
of times is different than the final
leader yeah and they often are flawed
because their job is to keep everybody
underneath them to not take their spot
right and I think most you know most
cultures just don't do a good job of
figuring out how to navigate that and I
my so my husband's an educator is a
teacher and a principal and he I always
envied him because to him it was all
about the kids is it good for the kids
if it's not good for the kids then [ __ ]
you were not doing it and I feel like
it's actually there is that there is
that and you've talked about it a lot
but I'm saying it's just not most people
do no it's not but no question I'm sure
of it customer absolutely the customer
doesn't give a [ __ ] that you make all
your money on cows or oil right they're
a customer right they're gonna live
their lives and if you don't kill
yourself to win for them it's game over
I don't give a crap when social media
disappears could care less
can't wait so that's been on your mind
yes cool final thoughts brother um just
first like thank you every for
everything you've done for me you know
from being in school to here and coming
here and having this conversation just
thank you like I really do appreciate
you and then too I got a piece of art
for you back here
yeah yeah and uh we do made that we did
a look my buddy graft on me super um and
then we do a little video to that - it's
on my Instagram you wanna check that out
I do man any video video word yeah so we
did something just based off your clouds
and dirty concept alright I will
everybody listening at home I hope you
got value out of this if you're super
bright I think you could make the
connection points that happened here I
thought was super rad I really enjoyed
this
I appreciate you 3 thank you so much for
coming in you keep watching